>> Greg: FOR THE MEDIA, IT WAS
THEIR MARCH MADNESS.
>> THE WHEELS OF CHANGE ARE
HAPPENING.
I AM GETTING CHILLS HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION NORTH OF THE
NATIONAL MALL WHERE WOMEN
SUFFRAGE STARTED IN CIVIL
RIGHTS.
>> THERE'S A HANDFUL OF MARCHES
YOU REMEMBER THAT OUR TOWN
REMEMBERS THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MARCHES OF THE '60s.
ABORTION RIGHTS MARCHES.
TEA PARTY.
MILLION MAN MARCH.
THIS IS RIGHT UP THERE.
>> THESE YOUNG PEOPLE WERE LIKE
THE ANTI-VIETNAM PROTESTERS IN
THE LATE 60s.
IT WAS THE BEGINNING OF A
PROTEST.
>> Greg: WHAT WAS ONE'S
PERSONAL IS NOW POLITICAL.
COMPLETE WITH SLOGANS, SIGNS, A
GUSHING MEDIA, MILITANT SALUTES
AND OF COURSE INVECTIVE.
>> I'M GOING TO PUT THIS PRICE
TAG HERE TO KNOW HOW MUCH MARCO
RUBIO TOOK FOR EVERY STUDENT'S
LIFE IN FLORIDA.
$1.05.
>> Greg: THAT WAS HARSH, BUT
WAS IT DARING?
NOT REALLY.
WHAT WOULD BE DARING IS
INCLUDING A PARKLAND STUDENT
WITH A DIFFERENT VIEWPOINT ON
GUN CONTROL ON THE STAGE.
WITH DAVID HOGG, HE IS JUST A
KID, RIGHT?
THE MEDIAS HAS OFF-LIMITS THAT
THE MARCO RUBIO THING, THAT WAS
LAME GRANDSTANDING.
IS THAT TOO HARSH?
NOT REALLY BECAUSE I CRITICIZING
HIM, I AM COMPLEMENTING HIM.
HE IS NOW A REVOLUTIONARY LIKE
ALL OTHER WELL-ORGANIZED
REVOLUTIONARIES, NOT CHALLENGES
REVOLUTIONARIES, NOT CHALLENGESC
REVOLUTIONARIES, NOT CHALLENGESA
REVOLUTIONARIES, NOT CHALLENGESL
REVOLUTIONARIES, NOT CHALLENGESN
REVOLUTIONARIES, NOT CHALLENGESI
REVOLUTIONARIES, NOT CHALLENGESG
REVOLUTIONARIES WILL BE
PATRONIZING.
THE STUDENTS OF PARKLAND HAD A
REAL GRIPE.
A CRAVEN SHERIFF DIDN'T DO HIS
JOB AS WELL AS AN INSANE KILLER
DO HIS.
17 PEOPLE DIED.
THE STUDENTS THOUGHT THEIR
SCHOOL SHOULD BE A SAFE SPACE,
NOT LIKE THE SAFE SPACES OF
OLDER COLLEGE KIDS WHO WEEP AT
THE HINT OF PAINFUL TRUTHS.
A REAL SAFE SPACE PROTECTED FROM
MADMAN AND WHEN NECESSARY
SHIELDED BY GROWN-UPS WITH GUNS.
THE SAME GOALS OF SENSIBLE
STUDENTS SHOULD NOT BE IGNORED
BY THE NRA.
BUT IF THE OTHER TRUTH IS
IGNORED BY PARENTS, GO ON
BLAMING GUNS FOR ACTS OF EVIL
INSTEAD OF ACTUAL EVILDOERS.
IN FOUR YEARS, YOU'LL END UP
WITH COWERING UNDERGRADS
MAJORING IN SANCTIMONY AND SIGN
MAKING.
THERE WAS A GREAT STORY AFTER
THIS.
KILLER MIKE, AN AMAZING RAPPER,
DID AN INTERVIEW ABOUT WHY HIS
KIDS WEREN'T MARCHING.
>> I TOLD MY KIDS ON THE SCHOOL
WALKOUT, I LOVE YOU.
IF YOU WALK OUT OF THAT SCHOOL,
WALK OUT OF MY HOUSE.
[LAUGHS]
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
WE ARE IN GUN OWNING FAMILY.
MY SISTER FARMS.
WE FISH, HUNT.
WE ARE NOT A FAMILY THAT JUMPS
ON EVERY SINGLE THING AN ALLY OF
OURS DOES.
SOME STUFF WE JUST DON'T AGREE
WITH.
>> Greg: HE HAD TO APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT.
JUAN, DO YOU THINK HE SHOULD
HAVE?
>> Juan: WHAT DID HE APOLOGIZE
FOR?
>> Greg: FOR WHAT HE JUST
SAID.
HE HAD TO APOLOGIZE BECAUSE HE
SAID HE WOULDN'T LET HIS KIDS GO
TO THE.
WAS THAT RIGHT?
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK SO.
>> Greg: HE SAID HE WAS GOING
TO ALLOW HIS KIDS TO GO.
>> Juan: ARE HERE --
>> Greg: HE APOLOGIZE BECAUSE
HE WENT AGAINST THE FOREST
ASSUMPTIONS OF HIS FRIENDS.
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT.
I THINK THERE ARE PEOPLE,
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
RURAL PARTS OF THE COUNTRY, AS
HE WAS SAYING, THEY ARE
ACCUSTOMED TO HUNTING, FISHING
AND ALL THAT.
THEY ARE MUCH MORE COMFORTABLE
WITH GUNS.
THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE.
THE ISSUE HERE IS WHAT HAPPENED
IN PARKLAND, WHAT HAPPENED IN
PLACE LOADS LIKE COLUMBINE,
ALMOST 20 YEARS AGO.
WHAT HAPPENED AT VIRGINIA TECH,
NEWTOWN.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
TO ME, I AM STRUCK THAT PEOPLE
WILL TRY TO DIMINISH THE POWER
OF WHAT HAPPENED OVER THE
WEEKEND.
THE INCREDIBLE TURNOUT, THE
NUMBERS NOT JUST IN WASHINGTON
BUT AROUND THE COUNTRY.
PEOPLE TRYING TO EXPRESS
SOMETHING IS WRONG AND WE NEED
TO HAVE HONEST DISCUSSIONS AND
CONFRONTED.
I WAS ON "FOX NEWS SUNDAY" WITH
NEWT GINGRICH.
THIS FORMER SPEAKER SAID WHO IS
PAYING FOR THIS?"
YOU QUESTION THE AUTHENTICITY
AND SINCERITY OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE.
WHY AREN'T THEY MAD AT SHERIFF
ISRAEL?
YOU CAN BE MAD BUT THE HEART AND
SOUL THAT IS THAT WE SEE
REPEATED VOCATIONS OF THIS KIND
OF INCIDENT AND ALSO THE ONGOING
ATTACKS IN PLACES LIKE CHICAGO
THAT WE OFTEN DISCUSS WHERE
HANDGUNS ARE USED BY THE GANG
BANGERS AND THE LIKE TO KILL
PEOPLE.
I THINK IT'S TIME FOR US AS A
SOCIETY TO BE WILLING AND DARING
ENOUGH TO STAND UP AND SAY WE
ARE GOING TO DEAL WITH IT.
WE ARE GOING TO STOP HAVING EASY
ACCESS TO GUNS EVERYWHERE.
>> Jesse: THERE IS THE
STRICTEST GUN LAWS IN THE
COUNTRY IN CHICAGO.
THE DEADLIEST CITY.
AT LEAST ONE OF.
>> Juan: YOU KNOW ABOUT
INDIANA?
>> Jesse: GUNS GET EVERYWHERE.
YOU CAN ALWAYS LIMIT ON SOMEONE
ELSE.
INDIANA, THE RUSSIANS.
THAT'S NOT THE POINT.
IT'S GOOD THEY HAD EMERGE.
I AM GLAD TO SEE STUDENTS ACTIVE
AND NOT PLAYING VIDEO GAMES.
YOU WANT PEOPLE INVOLVED IN
DEMOCRACY, AND THAT'S FINE.
>> Greg: WHAT IS WRONG WITH
VIDEO GAMES?
>> Jesse: NOTHING.
GET OUTSIDE AND GET SOME
SUNLIGHT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF
CONTRADICTIONS AT THE RALLY.
THERE WAS A RAPPER PERFORMING
AND HE WAS ARRESTED LAST YEAR ON
A WEAPONS CHARGE.
ONE OF THESE GUYS, CAVETT
PHILLIPS, A YOUNGER VERSION OF
ME, WENT OUT AND ASKED
QUESTIONS, WHAT IS AN ASSAULT
RIFLE?
NO ONE KNOWS WHAT AN ACTUAL
ASSAULT RIFLE IS.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE ARE BEING
PROTECTED BY HEAVILY ARMED
SECURITY GUARDS.
THE GUY, DAVID HOGG, I HAVE SEEN
THEM ON FOX NEWS.
HE STARTED OFF AS A BALANCED,
NICE KID WHO WAS REPORTING THE
FACTS ABOUT WHAT WAS HAPPENING
AT THE SCHOOL.
HE IS NOW BECOME A REAL BOMB
THROWER.
SOMEONE LIKE THIS I THINK ISN'T
HELPING THE CONVERSATION.
IT MAKES PEOPLE GET THEIR BACKS
UP.
THIS GUY MAKES PEOPLE THINK YOU
ARE COMING FOR MY GUNS.
YOU ARE GOING TO SAY RUBIO HAS
BLOOD ON HIS HANDS BECAUSE HE
TAKES MONEY FROM THE NRA?
MAYBE HE TAKES MONEY FROM THE
NRA BECAUSE HE SUPPORTS THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
IT WOULD BE MORE SCANDALOUS OF
THE NRA WAS BUYING OFF DEMOCRATS
AND THEY WERE VOTING FOR NRA
LEGISLATION, EVEN IF THEY DIDN'T
BELIEVE IN IT.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE TO
ME.
I ALSO THINK THAT WHENEVER
THERE'S A SCANDAL IN THIS
COUNTRY, THE LEFT AND THE MEDIA
BLAME REPUBLICANS.
THE NRA, FOX NEWS, TRUMP, BUSH,
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS.
IN THIS PARTICULAR SITUATION,
THE GUY HAD A RIFLE BECAUSE THE
BILL OF RIGHTS SET AN
18-YEAR-OLD WITH NO CRIMINAL
RECORD CAN HAVE A RIFLE.
IT WAS THE POLICE AND THE SCHOOL
AND THE FBI, THOSE ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO FAILED.
LET'S TAKE A BROADER LOOK AT NOT
JUST TARGET THE NRA.
>> Greg: KIMBERLY, THE THING
THAT TROUBLES ME IS HOW -- WELL,
IT'S AN EXPLICIT POINT YOU
CANNOT CHALLENGE SOMEONE OVER
THIS KIND OF IDEA BECAUSE THEY